let me take you back if i can to
september 1993
uh in the white house on the lawn
outside the white house
and you were there at that moment when
peace looked possible and you said the
palestinian state is emerging
yes what went wrong many things went
wrong since 1993. well beginning i don't
want to go through the whole history but
began with a very flawed
agreement frankly speaking that gave
israel power and control
and in many ways diminished palestinian
people's rights to
create sovereign aspects of statehood
so that was one too the fact that the
u.s maintained the position
of israel as our strategic ally israel
is our special ally israel can do no
wrong and therefore maintained israeli
impunity
and power without any kind of checks or
accountability
and that exists to this day and that
exists and has become worse
following the the four years of trump we
have seen
a deliberate attempt at bashing the
palestinians to submission
and at pandering to netanyahu and giving
him everything he wanted plus
some more and add to that the fact that
netanyahu has been
actually shifting the discourse to the
extreme right
and he said that openly he only paid lip
service to the two-state solution
what he wanted really was to superimpose
greater israel
on all of historical palestine what
about palestinian failures though what
about the divisions
within the palestinian political
echelons i mean
there is always this phrase that that
people trot out the palestinians never
miss an opportunity to miss an
opportunity but you have you have missed
opportunities no that's a racist
statement and i really can't stand it
when somebody says
palestinians never miss this is really
misleading and it's a lie
because i've been there and i've seen
what's happening
there was ill will from the beginning
against the palestinians and
look you have to place things in context
i'm not i don't defend the palestinian
leadership they've made we've made many
mistakes
but the issue is not that the issue is
that you are under occupation
the leadership has no power no sovereign
powers whatsoever
they don't control freedom of movement
they don't control airspace
sea space territorial waters
crossing points it's a prison there are
two prisons
and israel has been busy doing whatever
it wanted with full impunity
demolishing homes stealing more land
stealing resources
killing palestinians with no
intervention and the palestinians were
supposed to pretend that we were living
in a very normal situation where there
are two states
next to each other equal they have to
talk to each other
how do you talk to your occupier
how do you ask for permission from your
occupier to be free
so it would be very simplistic just to
say palestinian shortcomings yes we have
them
and many of them are internal and we
deserve better
but that's not the reason why
the the so-called peace process failed
there was no
intention from the beginning
to hold this into account to provide the
palestinians with
protection or to manage
to guarantee and protect the so-called
global vision of a two-state solution
so what happens now a two-state solution
is you say dead
correct i think netanyahu destroyed it
it's not an organic thing that you can
say die that has been
in many ways destroyed a one-state
solution is
it's not something the israelis will
ever accept so so where
what now it's not up to the israelis i
think to decide what to accept or not to
accept
but they do they they whether you like
they control they do control but the
situation
is changing now there is public opinion
that is moving and and influencing
decision-making
everything that israel used to do in the
dark is now in the open
people are seeing the brutality the
cruelty the lawlessness the criminality
of this occupation
and they're not willing to give it a
free hand the the public as usual is way
ahead of the governments
but they will be heard they will make a
difference this is happening now because
israel
also went too far and they thought they
could dominate the discourse and the
narrative
and continue to distort realities but
now it's
people have access to the truth to facts
on the ground and they are speaking out
so it's very important that that this is
seen for what it is
i think sooner or later there will be a
consensus
that israel is creating and it's
emerging is creating an
apartheid state this latest uh
eruption i would say and and
confrontations
took place among palestinians everywhere
in 48 palestine in jerusalem in gaza
in the west bank everywhere plus
palestinians in exile and the refugee
camps
so there's a unity of voice a unity of
vision and there is a solidarity
movement that is emerging
that is capable of transforming
perceptions and realities it will take
time yes
but i don't think israel should have the
veto power on anything
including international law and the
guaranteed rights of the palestinians
including the right to
self-determination
i just wonder the extent to which you
are worried that the
the support now among palestinians has
shifted
over to a to a much more violent form of
resistance in the sense that you know i
was outside the damascus gate when those
rockets hit
the hamas rockets hit near jerusalem
people cheered
outside the damascus gate hamas seems to
have a level of support
that we haven't seen for some time right
where where is this heading are we
seeing you know an anc
style african national congress style
resistance where
any israelis are our fair game
in this fight i don't think so i think
look palestinians started the armed
struggle
and had freedom fighters historically we
were part of a revolution
and it was a global revolution and
people were in solidarity with us a long
time ago including the anc
but the issue is is not that uh
hamas is going to gain and is going to
be really because hamas is not just
a an armed struggle movement or
resistance movement
it also has a social agenda an economic
agenda
and people don't necessarily agree with
the other
aspects of its agenda but
this came at a point of
extreme anger and sense of let down
they saw somebody something happening
instead of lying down and dying quietly
that some people are acting
and this i describe this as an antidote
to helplessness and hopelessness
the thing is that we're not going to
accept this we're not going but what
you're saying is that violence is an
antidote to
helplessness and hopelessness but partly
yes it became in the public
imagination i would say that we are not
helpless victims we are not passive
victims and we don't want to be
the the the fallacy of this is that
people see violence only when
palestinians resort to violence
and as you know any people under
occupation by international law have
the right to resist in every possible
way through
the international law but still israel
exercises violence on palestinians daily
a daily leaked palestinians daily
demolitions homes
daily at arrest people and yet the
narrative is the other way around
israel is portraying itself as the
victim exactly you see that's right
how do you switch that the distortion of
the narrative
and the the lack of knowledge of the
power asymmetry
have created two distortions and
unrealistic views of what's happening on
the ground
this has to be switched by by public
diplomacy by by a clear policy by clear
strategies
but more importantly by this emerging
network
of solidarity the protest marches
hundreds of thousands
people came out and said this is wrong
it's time to stop the injustice
exercised against the palestinians and
to stop the pain
seems to me israel is its own worst
enemy
by destroying the two-state solution and
by escalating the violence and
criminality to such a level
it brought the subject back to the
original issues of the creation of the
state
of the exclusionary nature of an
ideological system that describes itself
as a jewish state where only jews have
the right to self-determination
it brought back the issue to well where
are we what happened to the original
palestinians
indigenous peoples this is really
crucial now
and so the the whole nature of the
discourse is shifting
you can no longer expect israel to
maintain the control over the public
diploma and public discourse
and finally in a sentence what is your
assessment of
benjamin netanyahu's legacy
i think netanyahu's legacy has been one
of the most if not the most destructive
legacy
for israel for the whole region
and i think in in many ways by
legitimizing
fascism and violence and manipulation
and control as well as
corruption uh that he has
created a situation where the chances of
peace have become all that more
difficult if not impossible
and this legacy is going to last a long
time
because destroying the the the chances
of peace means that not only the
palestinians will pay the price
but also the israelis because there's no
way you can maintain
an exclusive control over the people who
are bent on getting their rights under
freedom